bonjour savez vous ce qu'est une cour
princière alors qu'il ya plusieurs sens
possible mais non mais c'était une
question rhétorique c'est pour vous une
cour princière ressemble à ceci on a du
pain sur la planche
et si vous êtes déjà en train de penser
à versailles désolé on est toujours aidé
liste ici que très pas si je fais but
[Musique]
dans cet épisode on expliquera et on
fera la différence entre les ternes de
cours princières et d'hôtels princier au
moyen-âge déjà le mot court peut avoir
plusieurs sens tenir sa cour peut
signifier rendre la justice pour un
prince il peut aussi s'agir de
l'entourage du roi ou du prince c'est le
sens du mot quand en anglais mais en
allemand le mot cours qui se dit of
désigne plutôt le lieu où se tient la
cour en français c'est donc un peu le
bordel puisque le mot court peut prendre
ces différents sens généralement la
course ça reste quand même l'entourage
du prince sa famille
des membres de la noblesse plus ou moins
en place et la course un petit peu son
gang sa team
et comme tout groupe on peut arriver que
ses membres soient modifiées au gré des
besoins de la vie etc
lors de certaines occasions comme les
cures plénière la cour peut être
composés d'énormément de monde et à leur
verse ce nombre peut être réduit
il ne se passe pas grand chose la
définition de la cour reste donc vague
et c'était déjà le cas au moyen-âge
comme le montre cette citation de walter
map du 12e siècle à la courge existe et
de la cour je parle mais ce qu'est la
cour dieu sait que je n'en sais rien les
membres de la cour ne sont donc pas fixe
et durant moyen-âge ses cours restent
itinérante parce que les princes adore
se déplacer de château en château à
chaque déplacement le prince emporte
donc tout ce petit monde avec toutes
leurs affaires
d'où l'importance d'avoir du mobilier
facile à déplacer
[Musique]
merci de penser un peu aux serviteurs
dans cette histoire justement pour
assurer le bon fonctionnement de cette
cour il fallait bien du personnel et
c'est ainsi qu'on en arrive à notre
deuxième définition les hôtels principe
attention comme pour la cour le terme d'
hôtel princier peut avoir deux sens le
premier conte détaillera pas peut
désigner une résidence médiévale et donc
la résidence du prince on trouve ainsi
de nombreux hôtels princier à paris dès
le xiiie siècle mais le terme d' hôtel
désigne aussi l'institution qui regroupe
les serviteurs d'un prince et c'est à ça
qu'on va s'intéresser aujourd'hui quel
métier pratique-t-il comment sont ils
payés qui sont ces gens quelles sont
leurs réseaux contrairement à la cour
l'hôtel prince y est une réalité
administrative dont on retrouve des
traces dans plusieurs types de documents
les ordonnances de l'hôtel qui sont des
descriptions de l'organisation de
l'hôtel et de ses différents membres et
les différents documents de comptabilité
parmi eux on trouve par exemple les
écrous de la dépense qui sont des
petites bandes de parchemin qui résume
les dépenses de la journée avant de
détailler davantage on peut donc résumée
comme ceux ci la cour princière est
composé d'un prince de son hôtel de
plein d'autres personnages importants et
de leur hôtel plus petits ça fait un
paquet monde le plus vieux texte
conservé régissant l'organisation d'un
hôtel princier nous vient denrées
premier beau clair le fils de guillaume
le conquérant
il s'appelle la constitutio de mousse
réglisse ou organisation de la maison du
roy et datent des années 1130 dans ce
texte on retrouve les noms des
différents membres de l'hôtel ce qui est
pratique parce que tout le monde avait
tendance à essayer de s'y incruster non
mais je vous jure je travaille ici je
connais des gens quand le château gm
tonneaux à l'intérieur au fil du temps
ce type de texte prend le nombre
d'ordonnancés de l'hôtel et remplace
définitivement la tradition orale à
partir du xiiie siècle on y retrouve les
fonctions précises des serviteurs qui
obéissent à une hiérarchie leur devoir
mais aussi leurs droits
l'un des premiers hôtels bien définis en
france et celui du comté de hainaut au
début du xiiie siècle c'est un comté du
nord de la france bien développé composé
de nombreux noble est donc bien
organisés administrativement on trouve
l'organisation de son hôtel dans le mini
steria courriers anonymes 6 les offices
de la cour de hainaut écrit par le
chancelier de hainaut gilbert de mons en
1212 ou déjà ce dernier nous explique
que le comté de hainaut est divisé en
trois circonscriptions mons valenciennes
et vost revend il existe donc une cour
du hainaut mais trois hôtels pour
chacune de ces circonscriptions
ces trois hôtels sont dirigés par trois
officiers au dessus de la division en
circonscription le sénéchal héréditaire
d'abord et le chef des valets du prince
on l'appelle aussi le dap y faire le
chambellan héréditaire ensuite veille
sur le prince en particulier son corps
et ses biens et enfin le bouteiller
héréditaire et celui chargé de
l'approvisionnement en bois sont parce
que c'est toujours important d'avoir une
bonne quantité de vin à portée de main
ces trois officiers se trouve donc au
dessus de la division en circonscription
est en dessous d'eux se trouve
différents autres offices héréditaire à
chaque fois en trois exemplaires pour
chaque circonscription
il ya par exemple le pompier qui fait le
pain et lemm tort escargot qui est
chargée d'acheter la nourriture
vous ne rêvez pas la plupart des offices
tourne autour de la bouffe normal chacun
de ses serviteurs a des droits et des
devoirs
par exemple le chambellan a le droit de
prendre une robe dans la garde-robe de
chacun des chevaliers au service du
comte de hainaut lecomte devait aussi
fournir des chevaux à ses officiers
ainsi que des gages de l'argent les
offices héréditaire été transmise de
père en fils mais elle pourrait aussi
être cédés contre de l'argent si le
compte était d'accord les bons comptes
font les bons amis
à la différence du comté de hainaut
l'hôtel royal des capétiens ne contient
pas de fils héréditaire le roi peut
librement virait ses serviteurs c'est le
souhaitent l'hôtel royal a sa propre
comptabilité
la première ordonnance de l'hôtel royal
conserver date 2261 on en retrouve
ensuite pour chaque changement dans
l'organisation
grâce à ces ordonnances on sais quel
office formé l'hôtel et combien chacun
était payé les offices était divisé en
six métiers principaux la panne et riz
pour la fabrication du pain
l'eschansonnerie pour le vin la cuisine
la fruiterie l'écurie et la chambre à la
tête de ces métiers se trouvent des
chefs de service qui sont plusieurs pour
éviter qu'une seule personne ne
travaille 365 jours par an
par exemple si on détaille un métier au
choix celui de la cuisine
d'après lordonnance de l'hôtel de 1291
on trouve 6 que les maîtres cuisiniers
qui se réveille donc à la tête du
service en dessous d'eux se trouve cinq
aide de cuisine de socié 4 souffleur qui
entretiennent le feu cet acteur ceux qui
sont spécialisés dans la cuisson huit
pages qui font un peu tout et deux
huissiers qui garde la porte
ça fait donc déjà 35 serviteur pour un
métier au total d'après cette ordonnance
il y avait cent soixante-quatre
serviteurs dans l'hôtel royal mais ça
c'est le chiffre minimum parce que
certains de ses serviteurs avaient eux
mêmes des domestiques qui n'apparaissent
pas dans les comptes
on estime qu'il y avait plus tôt environ
500 serviteur plus de 100 pour les
hôtels de la reine et des enfants ça
fait à peu près 700 personnes mais
n'étaient pas tous là en même temps à
cela s'ajoutent les hôtels de tous les
membres de la cour du roi et ça fait
donc du monde et du monde qui coûte cher
en 1250 les dépenses annuelles de
l'hôtel royal représente environ trente
six mille livres vous évoque peut être
pas grand chose mais des 1299 ce chiffre
augmente jusqu'à 250 mille livres ce qui
est donc beaucoup plus est cette somme
continue d'augmenter sous les valois ou
14e siècle l'importance de cette somme
s'explique déjà par le fait que les
serviteurs recevait un salaire régulier
des gages qui dépendent du nombre de
chevaux plus le serviteur est important
plus le concept de chevaux et donc plus
on lui verse d'argent pour nourrir ses
chevaux les gages ne permettent pas de
mettre de l'argent de côté les
serviteurs les plus importants le
chambellan par exemple reçoivent une
pension annuelle
en plus des âges y avait quand même
quelques bonus déjà beaucoup de
serviteur était nourri à la cour du roi
disaient qu'ils avaient bouche à court
et on fournissait aussi à certains des
draps des chandelles des vêtements tous
les ans etc
en plus de ça le roi ou le prince
pouvait offrir des cadeaux
extraordinaires lors d'événements
importants par exemple on pouvait
arriver qu'un prince donne des gages à
ses serviteurs pauvres pour qu'ils
puissent faire la confession annuel à
pâques ce qu'il fallait faire un don
après la confession
les autres dons exceptionnels ont lieu
lors du mariage d'un serviteur du
baptême de ses enfants de son départ en
retraite
le principe est aussi pour son serviteur
s'il est capturé et fait l'objet d'une
rançon
ou encore il peut rembourser les chevaux
du serviteur morts au service du prince
et finance enfin l'enterrement et la
messe du serviteur décédé dans cette
dernière partie qui sera plutôt longue
on va détailler les 10
ferrand métier qu'on pouvait trouver
dans un hôtel principe et comme on n'a
absolument aucun parti pris on va
prendre l'exemple de l'hôtel des ducs de
bourgogne au hasard déjà il ya le
chambellan le personnage le plus proche
du duc il possède une office héréditaire
est à la charge des valets de chambre du
duc qui sont forcément des personnages
de confiance allant parfois jusqu'à
dormir au pied du duc les chambellans
sont toujours issus de la noblesse du
moins à la cour de bourgogne et sont
sous la supervision du grand chambellan
être chambellan c'est l'office la plus
classe l'élite de la cour il arrive même
que le du cnom chambellan certaines
personnes à titre honorifique
juste parce que c'est classe ça fait
bien danser en dessous des chambellan se
trouvent les maîtres d'hôtel qui
supervise le travail des serviteurs
ensuite vient le service de la cuisine
très important parce que manger c'est
bien on est troublé que les cuisiniers
des soucier des apprentis des garçons
cuisine et des écuyers de cuisine qui
devait veiller au garde-manger et tenir
les comptes de ce qui est consommé
chaque jour les peu pouvaient e mail
acheter leurs aliments au marché ou
passer par des fournisseurs notamment
pour les viandes et les poissons il
avait sous leur autorité toute une
panoplie de serviteurs spécialisés dont
certains que j'ai déjà cité les hater
pour surveiller la cuisson
les souffleurs et bûcher qui
entretiennent le feu les potagers qui
font la soupe
les sociétés qui font les sauces les
porteurs qui nettoie et transportent les
ingrédients une cuisine peut compter
jusqu'à 17 postes différents à la cour
de bourgogne on compte 29 personnes dans
ce service en 1400 26 et c'est que le
début des réjouissances puisque le
service suivant est celui de la panne et
rit donc encore la nourriture
ce service est constitué de papier qui
ne se contente pas de faire le pain mais
doivent aussi supervisé l'achat des
fournitures de la table comme le linge
de table et bien sûr la chasuble et s'il
n'y en a pas assez dans les greniers du
duc avec tout ça il réalise deux types
de pain un pain de bouche pour les
nobles et un pain de commun pour les
pécores enfin le personnel
enfin il et puis trop ville dont un four
trop chaud la montée a pas le temps de
se faire et à trop d'errements amis donc
se démerde
ils sont assistés de sommeliers de la
panne et riz qui sont chargés de
l'approvisionnement fromage amber vie
et grands l'hypocras et d'oubli york qui
fabrique les oublis des pâtisseries des
quoi j'ai oublié passons donc au service
suivant la bouteillerie services
essentiels lui aussi le bouteiller du
dieu qui est assisté de vallée de la
bouteillerie éveil à l'approvisionnement
en vins produits directement par les
vignes du tube bien entendu mais quand
même en bourgogne ce service compte
aussi des écuyers et chansons avec à sa
tête le premier et chansons qui choisit
les vins du prince et peut les vendre
s'ils ne sont plus bons mais parce qu'à
mon époque on boit le vin direct après
la récolte le laisser vieillir c'est
surfait
on n'a pas le temps dans ce service on
trouve aussi des barillets des
sommeliers qui servent le vin et font le
compte de la quantité de vin consommé
par jour des pratiques en cas de
contrôle des porteurs de vin etc
c'est aussi ce service qui veille à
l'approvisionnement en verre et en
vaisselle précieuse
enfin le dernier gros service de l'autel
et celui de la maréchaussée
c'est à dire l'écurie dans ce service on
trouve une forge et une soixantaine de
chevaux donc ça nécessite forcément un
peu de personnel comme il ya trois types
de chevaux il ya trois types de vallées
les vallées des palfroy s'occupe des
chevaux de parade les vallées des
sommiers s'occupe des chevaux de
transport chevaux de somme et les
vallées des grands chevaux s'occupe des
grands chevaux des chevaux de guerre
ce qu'on appelle aussi les destriers on
trouve dans ce service des écuyers qui
s'occupe des chevaux de leur entretien
de leurs achats mais aussi une des
palefreniers et des maréchaux ferrants
un peu à part on trouve aussi les
chevaucheurs des écuries ce sont des
cavaliers spécialisés qui ont pour
fonction de transporter des messages
et si vous n'avez toujours pas trouvé de
métier qui vous intéresse parmi tous a
pas de souci et reste encore d'être pas
de fonction consistera papier il a le
service de la table avec les écus et
tranchant qui tranche la viande pour le
prince et les pages qui font le service
les médecins physicien chirurgie ra et
barbier qui sont tous rangés ensemble
parce qu'ils s'occupent du corps du
prince ils doivent donc être des hommes
de confiance surtout les barbiers qui
pourrait facilement raté leur coup le
coût du prince plus tôt certains
médecins sont très proches du prince et
peuvent même travaillé comme conseiller
et astrologue à côté mais c'est une
autre histoire que j'ai déjà raconté il
ya aussi les légistes qui sont formés en
droit et des secrétaires qui s'occupe
des documents du prince les membres de
la chambre de nier responsable des
recettes et dépenses du prince les
officiers d'armes très important on
trouve dans ce service les héros d'armes
qui sont chargés de connaître toutes les
armoires et de tout le monde ce qui est
très pratique lors des tournois mais ça
aussi on en a déjà parlé et enfin les
membres de la chapelle du cal là encore
c'est une fonction très importante le
lieu possède une chapelle à demeure dans
son palais mais aussi une chapelle
domestique chargée de le suivre dans ses
déplacements
[Musique]
selon les époques et les événements elle
est plus ou moins développés on trouve
une petite chapelle pour les services
simples et une grosse chapelle avec des
chanteurs des enfants de coeur pour les
grands événements religieux
ce qui est amusant avec la chapelle
c'est que pour avoir le meilleur chaplin
on pouvait facilement se les piquer aux
autres c'est comme ça que philippe le
hardi qui voyagent régulièrement à rome
débauche en leur proposant un meilleur
salaire trois membres de la chapelle
pontificale en 1391 puis à nouveau 4 en
1394 et un petit dernier en 1395 à la
fin les papes devient petit peu faire la
gueule même si je me suis basé
uniquement sur l'autel des ducs de
bourgogne
cette organisation en différents
services avec une division en métier
très précis à l'intérieur de l'hôtel
étaient représentatifs de l'ensemble des
hôtels princier des 14 et 15ème siècle
il peut y avoir des différences des
exceptions mais on voit par là que
l'hôtel était un service très organisés
bien délimitées institutionnalisée avec
souvent sa propre administration et ses
propres finances j'espère que cet
épisode vous intéresser ce qui prêtait
un peu moins à rire que d'habitude il
était un petit peu plus technique déjà
que les définitions de cours princières
et d'hôtels princier n'était pas très
évidente même à l'époque mais une
quantité énorme de métier a cité c'est
pour ça que j'ai viré la romaine aussi
dans cet épisode c'est pas du tout sa
période eu le réflexe nous embrouille je
valide totalement en tout cas le
prochain épisode sera plus festif et
donc sûrement plus attrayant mais comme
on reste dans l'environnement des cours
princières médiévale je pensais qu'il
était important de commencer par celui
ci rendez vous donc le mois prochain
pour un nouveau corner de prince au
revoir
[Musique]
la plupart des beaux succès contre sa
mamma mia
cela me plaît c'est la plaie cette
chaleur libérée
[Musique]